I mean I remember doing photo shoots and
like what I do the hamsa can like they
go here it was very unusual and kind of
having people run up to you and be like
you know loving me letter having met me
it's out of love you know I decided like
it just makes you feel great I just love
talking to my hands like he like dunno
making two chairs and I am seeing
emotions just woke up somebody think is
huge tell her I was on a sailboat in I
think we're all going saw these dolphins
passed by we're listening so super
awesome sonic remember I started writing
another song over that it's all [ __ ]
ha ha ha
that phone is a great soft
[Music]
running later shows I was going to play
with my ebook latest acoustic David
Bowie and Ricky scooters were opening
position and I never made it so I got
there it was already over and I remember
my my keeper major booster was looking
at me way with a lot of disappointment
and I had to excuse I don't even know
when to bring my I was late so that's a
good one I'll close up laughing up it
somewhere but some of the core I
remember that said I thought I was just
had two of my best friends from Sweden
were there and they were like who is it
happening it was a stove and I almost
burned my feet so I decided to be very
good it was like savings was like so
operating the sounds had to bond and
grab my friends likes like old grandma
the verbs that you were like lose the
fat survive and everyone would see long
and dancing it so much on you
[Music]
let anyone think that you can't do
something because you're a woman don't
apologize for yourself and just like
whatever you're feeling it's right I
know I can tell you that you've got
doing call and see choose yourself stay
that apps and have fun
[Music]
people that feed your mind all the
badass girls that are just feeling into
music right now I'm really really great
for kids the beard butit's
[Music]